So what did you say the right machine? What the double bubble? Yeah, you're benefit to
Having direct exposure to the bare skin
Yes
Yes, I would say so so you're going to get more power out of
The bulbs that so the only way that the double bubble or
Or the
The zinger bulb is stronger than the then the
Hammer tube is when you're touching it right to your skin
So if you want to get a greater penetration, let's say your cancer is growing, you know faster
We are gonna hit this as hard as I possibly kid. That's what using one of the other bulbs right out of your skin is
Gives you more power now the negative is that you just have to be aware as that you might get zipped with it
Some of the frequencies is gonna give you like an electrical stem
So you can't be it's not gonna be harmful or anything like that
But if you don't know that you're scared the socks off. Yeah, so
You can be aware that you're gonna you're gonna get you're gonna get shocked by some of the frequencies
So I never heard of that we had a choice in the bulbs like I was given a bulb and I never knew that there was any other ones to use and we there's there's there's there's other ones to use if you use them
Don't just the way that you know that they're on a stand like the double bubble that they're not it's not I don't think it's as beneficial
It's much clumsy or to use
That's the way true right really pushes them and they sell them that way
But if you took that
Like if you took the the plastic sheeting off of your hammer to when you laid the glass bulb right on you
It makes it a much more breakable bulb. So I do not recommend you do that
But you will get you'll have a little bit more power because the bulb is touching you the closer it is to you the more power you're gonna have
But you'll the side effect is that you're gonna probably get zigged too
So you you know, it's not a recommended way to do it if you look at the true right website
He also does not recommend you put the double bubble bulb right on your skin
I'm saying that if you are trying to get more penetration and try to hit it harder
Well, you know, you're not gonna get a whole lot more
But you may get a little bit more with the double bubble directly on your skin